i will member of that corner wim parliament
to screen again the collection that called
what this the dealer may all your dress
here on the us wim oakley
villa is that and philip had your fans
hit scratching
i hot moment and went full or if
copies to get together and for the
first time of the a couple of months at
least some of as a child participates in
person intense
imported conference chose something and
explore to a suit you the most x
0 3 times d min of exloo framework
unique in the  self and too the and reaction
to the specific
circumstances in which the corpse oasis
excesses many parents and in this case
is fortunately too many of you can
tribute and together we found in type and
and I lost and depot fun to them rose
president i change
and i hear stimulus package more than
to train your multi square the impact of
the land and budget with the firepower of
next generation you switch the budget and wear on
this and when you into
concrete action and this alle blu  eprint
for the future
for european universities and company
sa rub therefore this page to gather
was nothing sensible new symbol ice creams
innovation om men after all first it
reflects the wolf in nature of the unit
and oh so more c
de further integration
of the unit in mister is  of course it's
about beast and the common understanding
and joint needed as main
each and every case to be the side of
the european level but this will we see
cross is the trigger for kind of
marriage man and back has to
acknowledge the end
in or  course'
reflects adequately
in the budget
it secondly and peacock and buddy's
innovative power reflect this
bytes and the funding structure and this
stasses kind i know and they said this the
beginning agreed sink or young in
and they ball of money and tatty
facing the  icons crysis young tests
need solidarity again minute lee
mobile aiste about i subtleties in the
least the product life cent body ran
well at supporting half kl  eur by
cry things 17 just for workers and
businesses and but activating
this channel is gripless or disability
only bacon so member states the more
room
formula for it is the same time we use
we don't use the beautiful firepower
to boost i go for i
end preferably i  wants to import something
in that situation that kongo in ego's
parties and the long grandpa chat or what
very pension at itho redesign
the milk that one of a slow framework
there are always or well the budget for the
europe or twice the boys
get patient  by empty your head and
ante joop an integration process the cart
and patch it means
i phantom slipped point well i no soap
i was once a minute of science'
couple of years ago
but agree on facts
don't use this notion pico's for den
quantum you them and was once again allowed
unit path in pass director synthesis tip
frank opinion so that's why how is it
economic moment i'm going to type a bad [ __ ]
in mains i came then ran this
page is  not storm and rich santo car and
challenges wat ons anticipée de crucial
transformation good fairy think there for
climate action teachers party earth
had of allen
action
app will make sure this twenty sessions
as a feather
buy twentysix
show how important it this time de
europe league bikes  to save your hopes
different as an old om test we don't
allocate in green and digit i nuts
to great the jobs of come already in to save
your hopes there om the global still picos
is a first mover
week and
side that in this field  more than 50
percent of the modern and financial
framework in action rationally we chose
your power the space from got digital or
chose
research innovation space itself sometime
is strict grantnink
our strategic serenity
lex innovation century has them in deep
new account
ideal as the commission and  trichet bans
to last no effect where the a
few chip big boy by imerge
rods from dc car challenge this most
young and can you eat it  app supporting
all member states to fight tea parties
and paddles ricinus we ourselves went too much
way of de did i eat this
session on the rope a boy is an
issue we
he campenhout prefers to eat all this that
was in fact funding state chip is
already and success  story we them from we
who travels in from stick we
generally go something at the end of the here
one to rest in our your pan st paul's
remains a je that is the power of the
european bram is your east cindy
the international role  or theory was
as if for politics in
impact
it's a time we has that site this the
killers the brakes and your site or the
budget neon resources stuff helps dory p
next in a region bore and then sure
did you much it kempi up to the
challenge was old and july bottom in the
member states and we will still present
the sheer
alle pleins concerning new om
resources
this will fan of the euro pioneer in the
long time and we will this costs in a
sexual eat it is home for n  ot
like a significant ran the
budget have in flat is all videos
how interviewer condizioni di regime
to protect the unit financial interest
end respect devolo flow
i want complement excisting teacher form
and edition layer of protection of the
unit
budget
it is unfortunately departure to surf
the text ps in bed
he is president of the line
kind of feels more highlight in her
speech
suffered for all the stimulus package hey so
l'édition de power view op en ze
learning youn in
oualid okay ps3 cover of die briels
crysis how i spector camp is  to be it
of app af prix pandemic offspring levels
patient or nothing see nothing useful new
house pleaded central to it is the make
something about the procession about week we
bow them with unwe signal of
solidarity what our
or beach at designing all cried one
with  we are slow move
how do i find learn message all unit is
here to stay
we fed on the pinky ropes
credibility at mee jingle of thing was
old politics w  ilco's already a success
trial lesson right.svg polldaddy.com
the cups tissue of circle dance in this
lake struggle to get a with many
of all member states sofa
eleven member states he is complete
grip cream pense and to the série
dearest to the sorry  lot ref
and danced i prefer to do next you
this conference is a new word the
moments so take stock of all the
budgetary milestones we give chief so
often how is t stimulus package on this and
pictures the power of small ones have 10
forward-looking
and innovative million  in he stories to
be yourself convent what of course we must
not rest of all nails beautiful he is
k kettles becomes has site nothing in use
a change
this is our tool for the patient oh
boy want fitly party new challenges
and who doesn't
you innovative thinking  you radius is
experts police make-up and schools store
anticipée the debate sherry
solutions for tomorrow
so a looking forward to reflect in the
ghetto and the unit
there his show could i  nbouw impact of
al hunger associations and then den Hoogen
nature of the unit budget
discussion with you the future of the we
a budget is us ever discussion on the
future of europe
oh yes that again hand discussion about the
he is a limit it  impact on the
budget pico's is wino de budget is all
police
closet in fingers if yes glands
local political project is now in the
future what should be the cheese of the
union in shape had already
around the lobles time this has to be
reflected  in a and i know what [ __ ] okay
we has right chick i go and tmf what
he show in the sometimes people
have this to think about an ex mff and
the from all perspective and may also will
come by john direct get jan merchant and
check marks  never too early to state viking
he builds the neck mrf and to that end image
an old car rent-a experience and garden
he hope
do this conference kennel ready
eat lounge set this client of
necessary reflection and how is it he
must like door  kill them by president
why la fonda lime green my warm
weather partly
sanka for him key note address met not
only for this wat input title also for
her strong support
bladder muscle how and i was when i eat and
pack [ __ ] he budget not only will they
in  the dish a steep path int ip
address sink the no how i write
popped up just sayo last here and
so finally she state of all parents
crept
opinion just how and responsible for
all day success is so thank you very much
and their own zola  the floor is yours
and you can hit video dr ladies and
gentlemen
menu close awesome anne and george on abc
girl i simply your words desserts nobel
prize in physics
together with choco romana ben
electro swing bed and was like another
winner even though and has not  been much
en de spotlight
our european union oh no precisely
is budget
microcement dike discovered deck
groundbreaking research
claus hasselman en joggingpants quarrel
with backed by you funding and th  is shows
wat de fans al budgetcam i
demonstrating your nolimits of
expertise and scruples research
on hairdo is the power of the budget
it is full 115 million euros anyway
paint
de shows the strength of europe at
something but we can all be proud of
en  am delighted to be with you to da
da already your budget convention of even de
sony possible for jolly
of course the timing of this conference
could not have been better
the european commission has just download
implementing
de baby's package and finance teeth de
your budget of  rate am talking about the
multi and your budget and next generation
jewelry coffee clamp
income prices how to build turkana
to find one trillion you all for the
period form 2020 one two 2020 7
places key like a blue and 100
trillion you we
and they snap  chassis impressive
finger it is a statement about our
ambitions
of the future of arjuna
take the dress penguin they were no but we
have to step up all actions climate
change and eu  ropees leading the efforts
you can see this
noraly and arjan smits head and ambitious
goals on the way to natural
you can see this free size the first and
foremost
by looking at all but yet
to reach the use
20 types of t'mock if we don't invest
overcame full 117 million euros each year
the king by estimates and this is my
search percent of defense to the next
generation i you we and they multi and your
budget earmarked for tackling climate
change
the culture op poets its many words
motions
owino
bed is transition is  more difficult for
some ben vaders
this is true for simple for region but
still the level ii of coal and to
address this challenge wiggle budget
wc just transition fond of more than 9
10 trillion euros
and in addition we have proposed a
new social climate fund
how  is more than 70 billion joris
this is designed to help prince boys
and nobelhout as in particular on
their way to climb the news of youtube
pico's in this way you will le  ave no way
beyond
my second point is the digital
transition
the pandemic has demonstrated that europe
is not an few was the global
temperatures winegums the technological
innovation with investments
we have to close the gap
en was a new century bioclean budget
and next generation century
billion taking  a b i walked in the
starbucks
20% on the recovery and resilience
facility fans will be invested in the us
digital transformation
and the good news is that most member
states even exceeding the targets
at their fortresses digital like never
before
based on the 20 sex national  tweezers with
the sofa
wiessee
bed more than forty 6 million euros will
be spent on upgrading digital public
services and twenty for billion to
upgrade business and the nearer twenty
three trillion you are ready to have
citizens all classes already union to countries
skills needed for the  jobs of the future
together with numerous het 0
instruments like digital europe roba
this will significant speed u  p all
digital transition from digital
connectivity toe supercomputing from
artificial intelligence toe
cybersecurity
de twin transactions are at the heart of
all future prosperity and the well-being
of folio case
met de budget en next generation you wie
er transforming the qontinent
voor de decades het
en  how you call a helping to create
sustainable job of dat de pandemic
next generation you and long can
increase mobile greedy-p growth and the
european union barntrup recent
en of this brings how you thorns to
market and economy cactus and joyce
conference in de jopie  je
met next-generation you de european
union has become the biggest is we of
green band worldwide
and this is met bij je bureau in die
month for sustainable finance
zo it came as no show price dat
mijnnieuwe intro de marketing you to raise
money for  next generation ii you for the
first time de bonsoir seven times over
subscribe
en dus interest has not federt
quite de controller i almost re  ason
tissue and ahriman choisis van en level
times over subscribe and this is
excellent news
axel en news for growth and objective
and for the international role of the use
and there for my first and foremost want
to congratulate you you and your team
for making this success  possible i know
that there has been helpful of hard work
the heights of confetti girls
of course' budget of the size chance if
something so big
responsibility
pico's while on union is a fortress
more than ever before
death wishes collective recovery
wie mastic special care but this money
is use flappie
and effective lee
how you don't show
it avenue and efficient is meant for
thing test profibus and the line with
pool of flow principles
this is not only a violin rowing of a
democratic
theory zo creates trust for investors
and businesses it is crucial  time
and this is why we have great to introduce a
new conditionalis i mechanism
this mechanism is at the very heart of
next generation i  you we and they europe
in budget
my look forward to the decision of the
court of justice on this mechanism
icing this will bring clarity for
everyone in europe
picos investments act en een blue
chose to have better future
must not be allowed to disappear into
his channel
well
implementation is key specially for the
national plans that we carbon fiber
facility the centerpiece of next
generation ii you
in the coming months we will closely
monitor the progreso polyphonic cent
investments in something my dear the
swamp serious about africa who and what
the green digital and  sister and some
social fairness
and this is why we have agreed with
member states on a set of milestones and
targets dat have to be fulfilled
piccolo at experience oil what get mad
catz dam and make no mistake de rules
for payments van de wk in brazil
facility  at crystal clear
at we require that control and old
systems arm place
a private prevent the tact and
correct
even necessary  corruption fruit and
conflict of interest
but using the van sander the facility
micro this the people of europe
how on a full of this time we'll make
sure that this budget service voice wel
nou let me at the end
come back to our die serving noble  prize
winners once more
micros business budget of the
opportunities for researchers to be je
her or de korf
sms see
it is like a budget feel of
opportunities for young people to study
and work abroad
just think of the rasmus plus een brand
that is recognized for all  the world
it's the budget full of opportunity
when it comes to finding
booyah for sample working on new own
resources to help finance next
generation ii you
will make a few new creative modu-tool
and more sustainable
this is the budget for union dat
services oh  hi thank you very much for
your attention